thank you
[Music]
and welcome back to another awesome
episode of the careful boys where we are
currently
oh well for off the record with all
Anthony days nice
we're not acknowledging our amazing
guest Hannah
doing my best trying really hard do you
like that intro I gotta impromptu uh
have some fun with this uh oh yeah she's
like this
we got this in Mexico together yeah we
did you you could have stopped this and
you didn't
she encouraged it
yeah they were doing it
no you don't get one and I'm like she
goes I know you want one and I was like
it made him so happy
and I was doing that all day I feel like
Nobody Does it quite like you you know I
would love to do for the fans I'm just
gonna just go on a whim here I'm gonna
go ahead and request to switch seats
with Joe for a second because we want to
get them in the same frame yeah oh
lovers kiss kiss
because I don't know what's happening we
just we just gotta endorse this
chemistry there's no way we're not gonna
have him your ass is warm oh really
that's your ass is now yours is too
yours is actually not that warm why is
this so regular cold so what does this
mean it's all the ice training all right
so we're gonna go into a session of
couples counseling for these two oh and
I just want to make sure everybody's got
their questions and their advice we're
on the verge of breaking up okay yeah so
uh let's just just start with a couple
basic questions I want you guys both uh
answer at the same time don't look at
each other or anything like that we're
just gonna ask some basic questions I'm
gonna count down three two one and then
you both have to answer immediately
let's just see if we're on the same page
okay okay okay and
um let's make it easy do you want
children yes
okay cool
how many children three two one go three
that's very good yeah okay and uh what
uh biological gender first girl boy
three two one go
I say go okay oh like I could choose is
there a reason why you want
I I think the dining
store is good
um how so I see what you mean I think
girls take care of the the whole yeah I
think so too I think like based on my
experience
but it's a different relationship
between an older sister and younger
siblings to an older brother did you
have is there is your oldest sibling uh
male or female male
experience I wish it was the other way
did you feel like you had an extra
parent than a brother no because we're
very close in age like we've only like I
think my mom had all of us four kids in
like four and a half years wow age isn't
like big enough for it to be but I felt
like
me and my mom's relationship I like cool
I think a girl would be good for slavery
reasons because
um she expand on that what if you just
stopped for slavery reasons next
question
next question unanimously and don't ask
me about that
moving on because girls they'll take
care of the kids
okay wow so it was actually on brand
exactly what we thought because they'll
treat them like dolls I did that who is
more sexually dominant three two one go
me yeah you yeah you probably there's a
little hesitation there I think it
depends on the day that's true okay then
who is more sexually creative three two
one go me oh no actually no I think I
lean into it more but you come up with
the idea okay so what's what how are you
more creative I don't know like Who's
down to do weirder stuff yeah I think he
comes up with ideas like what like
outfits things like that
I like enact it what kind of outfits
she's wearing an octopus costume
but she's like a fashion designer so she
made it herself you know it's like
Perfect characters
or lingerie both but I think like he
comes up with the ideas
what are you talking about yeah octopus
yeah
sometimes I like to structure it out too
like I like a to-do list of songs
what's like a what's like a I like her
sex checks we're gonna take a bath
because imma scrub you and after that I
will come over here I'm gonna lick your
balls first I would do that and I'll be
like that's a dope checklist do you guys
ever use food inside looks I don't like
food in bed it doesn't like food in bed
oh that's right continue an issue for us
so you would like to use food but he
doesn't like I'm gonna use whipped cream
do it on the couch yeah I don't need
that [__] huh
naked sushi man
oh dude that would be amazing
you guys just turn into like having a
dinner instead of sex oh yeah we'll just
eat strawberries and we just end up like
let's put on a show
exactly strawberries are good what city
do you ultimately want to settle down
three two one three cities-ish no three
City wait three cities what city what
city I don't know if it's like I think
ultimately we'll stay in America
probably oh really I think so oh really
I think oh you you sound like you have a
thought out how come you said oh really
he will go with what I want ultimately I
think he's like oh really I think he
would I feel like you've always talked
about like in the UK for the healthcare
you know what I'm saying well I think I
would pop well so right my thinking is
that I think he wouldn't be as happy in
the UK because the weather because his
friends are here friends like family and
I think like I like it here I feel like
I fit in in yeah yes yes yes
[Applause]
like these [__] don't yes I don't
know how you would do in the UK I think
people would like you but I mean as in
like I don't know how you would like I
have friends there and I make friends
way quicker than you do you do but I
think knowing but I would miss my
friends I think so I for me the reason
why I answered the way I did is because
it's in different stages of my life it
will be dependent on that so like I
could totally imagine being there
if we have kids for a moment yeah I see
what you're saying because kids for a
moment because because like well
depending on what age abandoned them
she has a massive family and I'm I'm
sure your parents would want to be
around them right and then and then so
that that whole that whole thing but how
long will stay there well like my life
goal has always been having several
different places that I live seasonally
yeah I just want to convince some people
in my family to come here and that can
happen too yeah yeah the kids and things
like that but we'll see what else but I
haven't really fell in love with the
city yet to want to go this is my place
yeah I kind of like going around because
I could think about five years at a time
but that wouldn't be like my 20-year
place I feel like you guys being Nomads
is like definitely you we're pretty
nomadic yeah all right which accent
would you like your children to have
three two one I'm gonna say say American
passport British accent oh wow I think
that's how you get by in life that's
tight yeah that's [__] mad I don't
know how we would do that Bonkers mate I
want them with a Chinese accent
it's not online Chinese accent
they can't even come I can't even see my
old kids because it's so hard
yeah if you have a child what genetic
features do you want for your child
versus the other oh
mate I mean the sun is only getting
closer so they really can't have my skin
tone like that's just damage Joe's skin
tone okay they just need melanin like
it's it's bad I've got Sun I'm getting
freckles I burned really quick huh yeah
we can't be dealing with that
um physical features I don't care I kind
of think we're gonna have ugly kids
like like black hair but red mustache I
don't know I just got this feeling
they're gonna be like good people like
funny
but I saw a picture of a Japanese ginger
boy and therefore made me want to kick
him in his stomach and run wait well oh
can you make make their kid
regret it three to four kids right yeah
so you got three to four chances now
it's a good odd looking good he's very
symmetrical oh we heard yeah yeah
especially his penis on his penis
too which one you know
it's gonna be bad I think maybe he's got
more fashionable like he's got the big
mouth how do you have a fashionable
mouth oh it's fashionable she's in
fashion dude she knows what's up lip
injection your guy's baby's gonna have
beautiful hair beautiful hair oh for
sure the hair game is gonna be nice yeah
hair game is gonna be like um he's more
symmetrical than me yeah so I would go
more your my face maybe if it's a girl I
think she would look better like you not
like me I think
dude racial babies are always beautiful
hello to Melvin jitsukawa
see do you see what I'm saying I mean
it's not stuck in like the 70s why is it
still super Asian yeah it just because
it was a bad angle probably that he was
also laughing yeah yeah yeah yeah he was
like wait if you if you switched it and
you did her photo so yeah start with her
photo and add his genetic that [__] is
kind of ugly so yeah I did do it over
do it over yeah that guy looks like he
[__] has he he runs on a cart and has
people sitting in the back
I would prefer to have ugly kids why
better character yeah and then they can
sort it out when they get older yeah I
mean
say your greetings to Sir William
jitsukawa oh that guy's good looking
good
taco face good looking what's that
expression it's just eyes closed it's
about to sneeze it's an expression of
indifference to the world it's a weird
expression but that guy looks like a
tick tock star he looks like he's coming
right it should have a difference to the
world you're like what do you think
about the political climate I don't care
I don't care I don't I literally I
literally don't care
I'm thinking here
that's peaky blinders he is yeah
remember where to live he looks like a
Tick-Tock star yeah without wearing his
glasses he looks like he's saying isn't
it
I mean that's fine I don't care yeah I'd
rather than be ugly anyway this a gerbil
nice right there oh I didn't notice cool
okay um how about this uh who in your
opinion would be a better parent during
the
child years versus the a teen or young
adult years oh
oh why and I just yell at them and you
can't yeah
I'll do better in that like
that like the nurture part of it yeah
but then I think like it gets to a point
where he'll need to take over and
actually get them to be adults well at
least you got both fronts covered
instead of both of you being on the same
side because I think yeah one thing that
I like
um uh watching her do is interact with
younger people and like also she's a kid
magnet like every time immediately kids
would just run up to her and like touch
her hold her all this stuff and it's the
weirdest thing like recently oh you know
Justin Shawn I I ran into him at Costco
because we were just hanging out oh he
lives in Hawaii he lives in Hawaii now
and then like out of nowhere right his
daughter wants to hug her and then just
and then it's always like this she's
like a kid magnet and then there's
there's it's funny because you know like
our friends kids will be like playing
with us and she like one might be scared
of me but not even to her so it's like
but I think that's developed over time
too I feel like your body gets you ready
for it
um like I'm giving up some sort of like
pheromone
yeah that's like she needs to or they
just think you're like a princess figure
I would like to believe that I just
but also the way that you speak to and
like talk to like some of the uh you
know employees and stuff and like just
watching the interaction how you teach
and how I'm like okay I can kind of see
how you will treat younger people and as
a parent and I'm like that's that's good
you're very nurturing it's very
different from me because I'm like I'm
always trying to make people sing I
think you need that though yeah because
you're like oh we need to do this and we
need to do that and I'm like no no they
need to learn yeah because they'll sink
in this instance but they'll learn yeah
whereas I'm more like I'll lacks it for
them but that's how you're probably
raised and stuff too huh I was raised
neglected so it's like he wasn't raised
as much as just grew up yeah so sinking
he's more braised yeah braised that's a
good team good balance yeah chemistry
yeah you probably need that right yeah
but I I don't think you do it too much
though because there's some people I
think it's just so much to the point
where it's overbearing but you're not
over bearing I think you're like you
care a lot and you try to fix it to the
point but you make the path too easy so
then they don't
and also you try to cover you try to fix
it before it gets messed broken but I'm
like that's a great experience for them
to [__] up a little bit yeah who's the
messy one in the relationship three two
one I think we're both messy in
different ways yeah I think I'm messier
than you actually yeah that's a wild
thing because they all know me as being
[__] up he's pretty like clean in the
house though he got annoyed at me for
not washing the dishes properly I mean
if he doesn't want you leaving crumbs in
the bed it sounds jealous
yeah I am messy and I mean have you seen
my office yeah but you're like that's
what that is that's what I am I'm a
world-class collector yeah he collects
but I grew up in a bigger family so I'm
used to like a little mess uh like it's
manageable yeah there's a little stuff
around and things like not dirty but
just four kids in a house
but my recent like orderliness that's a
new part of my life oh really yeah like
it's very recent when my friend taught
me how to design that room yeah and then
like now my room feels like art so then
I don't want to destroy it yeah but
before I never had that mentality
everything looked like this office here
if I'd have met you earlier I could have
been in the bed all right would you guys
so close would you guys do uh a prenup
or no prenup three two one no no time
she's taking everything oh really yep
I don't have anything
that's actually that's why she's
laughing and crying looked I know what
you've got it's fine you have a classic
car that you can take and some stuff
maybe I don't know pretty cool classic
car take his paddle board you could take
back what you bought just take the
paddle make it useless
make it hurt
yeah well she told me she doesn't oh
never mind you find out that you're uh
one of your children is uh gay who's
gonna take it better the first time
around I don't think any of us would
give a [__]
honestly I don't even think I don't even
think they'd have to come out like
because then I just think they could
bring sauna they could be fabulous right
out the puss dude straight up hey
I don't even think it would be
oh this could be all this confetti comes
out I'm born
that's a sassy baby you can stop pushing
lady
took you long enough yeah
you're gonna cut this thing or no I love
this dude yeah that's the umbilical cord
I think there's very little we would
care about
yeah I haven't really put much thought
into like I don't know I think like I
would say a decade ago I'll be like oh
yeah you know when I get my kid I'm
gonna be like this and this and I had
all these like ways of controlling a
mini version of me but then now I'm just
like that's a lot of effort to put a lot
of your expectations into another human
being just like yeah let them born and
hopefully you know you can make sure
that they stay alive and then they have
a good set of that's a good goal you
know of like like and and and yeah and
then they just get the love that they
need in a good environment and I mean
what else you know as long as I don't
know so what's a deal breaker for both
of you in this relationship
um deal breaker we were talking about
this the other day yeah
yeah I don't I don't like the idea of
like ultimatums of like if you do this
this is going to be the consequence
because you don't know it depends on the
Stitch situation in the moment from that
smelly [__] but really you gotta keep
that [__] clean yeah so I'm running
that's why he made you shower the first
time dude
just in case he's like we're not ruining
this any opportunity
I'm just kidding it's a good boundary
yeah it's bad it's a smelly dick I could
deal with a lot to be fair asymmetrical
shaft
breaker if anything happens to that two
inches she says I could even cheat and
she won't even leave me
terrified
it sounded like it should be that broad
no I didn't say that because I'm like oh
it's like I know so my thing is I don't
believe in saying this is the only
outcome to that solution so like if he
did that
there would be a reason for it right
that's like a symptom it's not the cause
he's horny if that was literally it and
then we weren't [__]
but then if I think if he was horny
beyond what we were doing he should tell
me about it and then we can arrange
something yeah because then the issue is
communication yeah then the issues yeah
so I think the issue is always deeper
yeah and then it depends on so it's not
going to be like I'll break up with you
because of the cheating it might be I'm
breaking up with you because of the
reasoning or it would be like oh that
doesn't matter that's just a symptom
let's deal with the cause but what if
you caught on cheating uh with like I
don't know like Bart
and he's just like he was just like saw
that coming oh whoa I think that would
because Geo's hot I think we could make
that work like let's all move in
together
I get to see tacklemore
God I got two daddies
yeah
he would as well if you're in school
like I got two beds so if Joe like
murdered somebody would you help him
cover it up why did he kill them and who
did he kill ah because that would depend
your mom
[Laughter]
damn well I had to make it like
realistic she's like what did she do if
it was a stranger she'd be like I don't
give a [__] was it like an accident or
if he maliciously just hate that [__]
they never got along and he was just
like we cannot be together because she
will never approve approve we've got
kids at this point
um no no kids how old we're dispensable
because if she's on the way out anyway
like if she's got five no it's happening
like tomorrow oh tomorrow oh
Chevy yeah that might be it I mean your
dad and brothers might kill me before
you yeah oh that's right what if he what
if he killed like a like a server at a
restaurant because they were being too
mean and they overcharged him for
something and he just snapped he just
snapped well then we gotta get in
counseling but would you would you turn
him in oh no so
so the restaurant saw yeah
but it was a situation like Joe gets
pulled over and then it's like an angry
cop or something for some reason he
pulls a gun out right he pulls a gun out
Joe thinks he can handle situations so
he's like wait what the [__] like he can
Joe already feels like his life is in
danger so he tries to like pull the gun
out of the cop's hand they get into a
wrestling match and Joe accidentally
kills the cop Joe freaks out oh [__]
because he knows what happens to the
news so he starts driving away on the
news Joe's a wanted man like like uh
America's number one wanted person he
comes home you've been watching the news
he comes in yeah he goes babe we're
going to [__] Mexico do you go what
do you do do you just follow him to the
end of the Earth Bart's like all right
so chapter one right
and things that never will happen
do you do do you like go to wait we
gotta think or do are you do you just
follow or do you wait for season two to
find out where the plot goes yeah we go
to Mexico and work it out there surely
right because there's no way he's
getting out of that like if you kill him
I'm not coming back to America it
depends if you get a good lawyer do you
know what I mean there's ways we can
maybe work it out but you go to Mexico
and work it out there right yeah but
you've already Fleet though let's go to
America though then you keep going
then maybe we hide
good lawyer
and then I guess I don't know work out
how to wire you money in prison is that
what you do jeez I guess you'll figure
it out I mean that says a lot that says
enough that you're willing to go that
link yeah that's really cool go to
prison for that
am I allowed in a long time yeah Joe's
technically innocent it's just though if
you go to a prison for a long time am I
allowed to [__] other people yesterday
you said that if I died you wouldn't
[__] nobody but if you're in jail it's
different and I told you I told you you
should [__] somebody yesterday he said
if I died you wouldn't [__] nobody
because I was at lunch
how do you just start saying that I
think we were there you guys have had
some crazy conversation the last 24
hours hypotheticals are fun though the
one we keep having is like he wants to
if he's in hospital and he's like in a
coma and there's no coming back kill me
he wants me to switch off the machine
yeah that's hard you think you could do
that and then the joke is you're gonna
everyone's gonna be saying goodbyes
while bar just walks up and unplugs it
in the middle of it and he's like what
you guys yeah taking too long because I
couldn't do that and then one tear from
Barton these beliefs yeah
just walks out like what are you doing
how how long though like not just not
like 12 hours right 12 hours a coma it's
got like a week or something she just
got in yeah you get the call like he he
just got into the hospital okay yeah he
would if he me rugby tackling bot like
it's not even an hour and then I was
like we've talked about this
and the doctor said there's a 90 chance
of survival
he said what he said and sometimes you
see Joe go
the part just goes yay
but the first plug is like to a lamp
sound like you're okay on the calendar
but it's like oh [__] wrong plug oh [__]
the light went off awesome TV why is
this place have so many outlets
I might look like a prostitute or
something
but I'm still alive in prison no I said
if I die oh she died
consequent visits why is it that if I
died you won't [__] anybody but if I'm
still alive you will still [__] that
doesn't make any sense to me because one
I can ask you directions permission
permission and you're [__] yeah but
I'm a go I'm dead you don't have to [__]
you don't have what if you like stood in
the room watching me get railed by some
other guys I'm not gonna make you stop
no because I gave you permission I'm
dead I know I can't bang you anymore so
I'm like I'm dead I'll [__] some ghost
girls or some [__] you're gonna [__]
Girl Scouts yeah so like
[Applause]
no I'm saying that if I'm dead we can't
even cross path in the same Dimension so
go [__] whoever you want if you die if
you don't hold me I'm gonna be pissed
yeah but if
I'll haunt you but I'm [__] I'm getting
some ghost [__] because that's a
different dimension do you think you can
feel it yeah I mean we're in the same
Dimension that's really
hurts what does it make sense is I get a
traffic ticket I get I go to [__]
jail and you're already banging a
prostitute you killed a cop in his world
trap the chicken this scenario is
realistic it isn't for two weeks and I'm
like I need to get some and I come out
like what the [__] you guys get each
other for real but if he's a ghost
you're like betrothed forever yeah if
I'm dead goes he's like I'm never having
dick ever again but what if I get a DUI
I don't even drink alcohol I'm in prison
for like a week and you're like I [__]
five hookers and I'm like
I meet another guy and then we're
together and then in my next life I find
him and not you
oh see yeah
right check and mate thank you that is
true that's a good point wow yeah that's
a golf club right there wow I never
thought of that I never thought about it
you reincarnation thinker
foreign